what's going on reject nation greg and
john here
this came out yesterday i don't think
it's an official trailer number two
everywhere i went on our notification
bells for all the movie trailer sites
we're saying it's trailer number two i
saw
that this went up about an hour after
john left my place after recovering the
steiner cut trailer i was spending
valentine's day with my fiance barely
spent time with her on her actual
birthday a couple days before so i was
like this has to hold off until today
have a personal life i want to check
this out i hear there's plenty of new
footage in here so that excites me and
then of course after we do a reaction to
it we'll
go through the frames and uh talk about
it a little bit more in depth i'm
excited about this more excited than
before because i recently rewatched the
godzilla 2014 movie rewatch console
island just gotta re-watch godzilla king
of the monsters so i'm just doing like
my
my rebuild up to getting this
mid-march let's get into it people
poor guy
oh damn he totally loses this fight
doesn't he
yeah i don't know this first fight
probably
sleep down
oh no
wow oh dude
i definitely get why specific room
especially gets referenced
oh that last shot
that looks so cool yes it looks so cool
let's go through this
let's go through this that was awesome
it was that was like
a pretty good amount of new footage i
mean based off of this footage right
here
at the navy port which like i don't know
how these ships can withstand the weight
of these two titans
you know he only weighs about like three
airplanes but in this fight sequence i
mean you see him going down
underneath the water maybe this is early
on in the fight but i love how even when
he's underwater yes water
blue okay but it still is such a
reflection of you're in godzilla's turf
yeah like the color schemes that
this movie has especially they've been
holding on since console island and king
of the monsters is godzilla's
more blue kong is more of the red
lighting and then here
underwater it's like oh no you're in
godzilla's turf so i
i could see a scenario where kong does
ultimately lose
this first fight they have a rematch
here and by the way that is such a good
atomic breath shot
my god that is monstrous
epic doing a good job of making godzilla
look menacing
that looks like adam and anime i [ __ ]
love it so much
so this shot right here when he's
falling down is this part of that
night fight or is this part of the navy
battle fight that looks like it's in the
city
it looks like it's probably in the city
okay yeah but this
looks like this is after the navy battle
fight maybe they wash up on a shore or
something yeah exactly yeah maybe
there's a beach
i mean it just seems like in that first
fight you're in godzilla's territory
that he's probably going to lose
yeah uh established underdog status for
kong
and then it looks like these two guys
are monarch like pacific rim
much in here that's like oh i get it
this really does feel like pacific
they're both with the monarch people and
just
the particular neon and shininess of the
city
it's aping godzilla anyway pacific race
but uh yeah i mean i'm definitely
getting those vibes which is
interesting to me and then with this
little girl who i'm i'm assuming
especially after watching kong skull
island i'm assuming she's one of the
girls from
within that tribe of the the the homo
sapiens that inhabit
kong skull island and she's right here
doing sigh language
and please be careful i put a lot of
money on this fight
i'm set to lose millions of dollars if
you go down
all right they didn't send me my
stimulus check because we don't qualify
we need to get another sequel on the
ground get up
get on your feet be the king this also
did give me my first bit of like oh
i i might actually want to root for kong
a little bit
it is putting me in conflict yeah
especially because after
godzilla one where he is the hero of
that like they need him to defeat the
mutos
and then they need him especially and
godzilla king of the monsters he is a
hero but it seems like with these
trailers they
really are pitching kong as the underdog
yeah and i love this shot
because one thing that i really love
about godzilla
2014 is how much so much of it majority
of it is all captured from
the terrifying human experiences their
perspective
not just the way it's scripted but also
the way everything is shot
they always capture from like you cut to
random strangers from within buildings
or tourists or whatever
and then here this seems like such a
scary moment
to be a human in a building and you're
like we gotta get the hell out of here
oh my god it's
who's gonna fall over and just watching
this fight take place it does remind me
out more out of the gareth edwards movie
more than it does like king of the
monsters or kong skull island yeah
definitely it has that sort of horrific
sense of scale that makes these you know
makes you remember that these are
monster
sort of horror movies in their own way
as well as action well the first one's
more of the horror movie
cox gold island king of the monster's
heart but the first godzilla definitely
has a horror tone to it then of course
the mechagodzilla moment and i'm just
wondering how this is all gonna play in
it seems like they're really rooting for
kong at least to set him up that he will
win yeah in the second fight i'm more of
team godzilla we gave a lot of
reasons in our video that we did that
was specifically dedicated to who we
think will win and why the 10-minute
video but the basic nutshell version of
it we don't think
that touhou would let godzilla
lose in this installment especially
after how king kong vs godzilla took
place they are borrowing godzilla for
this movie
i did hear though after putting out that
video there's one
thing that could be an exception here
and i don't know how much of this
is true godzilla can lose if he has a
son like a baby godzilla and there have
been leaks
one that just confirms with the toys the
toys themselves they have those
toys something that happened with
avengers it happens with a lot of movies
all this
has to be taken with a grain of salt
we're going off of toys here and
sometimes they do factor in
or they could just be a toy but there
are like a mechagodzilla toy and there
is a baby godzilla toy so
maybe gong does win in
the second fight but i'm like okay but
if it's all centrally focused
on godzilla versing kong how does
mechagodzilla factor into this is going
to come in randomly
at the end like yeah like having a baby
godzilla like okay this makes a lot of
sense like maybe we don't realize that
until the
end and then kong will win but then this
new godzilla will arise and blah blah
but with mechagodzilla i'm like is there
gonna be like a frankenstein
sea plot that's like shoved in here
again it's that promise that adam
wingard made of one of them will
definitively win and lose that makes me
wonder how mechagodzilla could fit in at
all
and there's going to be at least two
fights yeah so
it seems like it would stand a reason
that you would get like a fight early on
and then you build up to the big final
fight at the night time where god where
king kong has his axe
and then maybe does win in that fiver
i'm like how does mechagodzilla fit into
this because i was
what do you think they build
mechagodzilla to help godzilla practice
people people are back in godzilla and
they build him
so he can build up his skills i mean i
was thinking that maybe there's a
scenario here godzilla does lose and
maybe he does die
and then they tease that there's he has
a baby they also tease the events that
mechagodzilla will come around in the
sequel yeah and then so kong has to deal
with mechagodzilla then
baby godzilla grows i don't know that
doesn't actually make any sense that
sounds stupid
ignore all that because mechagodzilla is
in here causing destruction so there's
no way you could just
set up like we built a robot post-credit
scene because it's literally a
destruction scene
unless they want to spoil that up front
yeah i feel like that child that kong
relationship's going to have a lot of
heart
i really feel like i'm already feeling
for it maybe i'll care for a human in
one of these
i really care about the humans in 2014's
godzilla so we'll see how it goes down
here guys subscribe leave your thoughts
down below hit that like button click
that notification bell last but not
least
deonte w tongue punch fart box you know
how this is going to go
all right look you know how this is
gonna go we're doing a versus yes john
that's
that's john no i'm gonna say
something anything i was just talking
about
this is my way of saying i'm not going
to come in and talk about
anything on top of your joke you didn't
even get a chance to
tongue punch fart box you know maybe
godzilla
it's ruined you know something about
kong punching godzilla's
tongue and farting in it
good money for this hey look man
next month's shout out is going to be
the bet you're not you're going to be
blown away your socks are going to be
across the room that's how much of
knocked off they'll be i'll learn to
speak
better by the way done it's done